do you need a spare key for your Honda
vehicle well I'm Mike with Tom's key
company today we're taking a look on a
Honda CRV
for all sorts of vehicles out there so
come check us out tomskey.com today I'm
going to show you how you can order this
key programmer and we're going to
program two spare keys it only takes a
few minutes it's super easy you just
download the app and then plug this into
your car so you can make new keys for
your vehicle Tom's key company is all
about making it super easy and saving
you a ton of money over the cost car
dealerships want to charge for a spare
key let me show you how it's done
you need to find where your OBD2 port is
come by the gas and brake pedal look
around
until you find a plug you can fits this
you're going to plug it in
now to make it a little bit easier I'm
going to use this extension cord
and plug in the programmer so you got to
have a key that starts the engine in
order to use our equipment to make
additional keys today we're going to be
making two spare keys so we'll have a
total of three when we're all done to
help keep them straight I've got the
tile key finder on the original it's the
Honda logo you can get this and it pairs
to your smartphone so you can always
find your keys then we've got the one
key has a key ring another key without
the key ring to begin you got to get the
app on your phone and then you go
through a pairing process it's going to
tell you to scan a QR code make sure you
scan the right one one of them is for
instructions the other one is right here
and
One Stop scanned it'll tell us a few
things we got to have a Wi-Fi connection
we've got to have our original key and
we've got to have our programming easy
installer programming tool
okay then you need to get the put the
vehicle information sometimes the VIN
scanner works sometimes it doesn't so
I'm just going to go ahead and plug in
that we've got a Honda this is a CRV
and notice there's a couple different
ranges 2015 to 2020 and if you come in
here this one's asking for a smart key
we don't have a smart key a smart key
you'd push a button on your dashboard to
start the engine this one we put a key
in and turn it to start the engine so
that's wrong we got to come back to the
2001 to 2020. this is a 2014 CRV that
we're working on today
and we've got a blade key okay I'm going
to take my original key put it in the
ignition and turn it two clicks to the
on position I'm not starting the engine
foreign
we've got some communication going on
so give us some instructions we need a
paired key required to perform
programming so we need a working key
that already starts the engine we can
make up to five keys and we're selecting
what kind of keys program so what's
going to happen is we're going to try
this key that has the key with remote if
that doesn't work we may need to do this
option over here we're going to make two
keys and none of those we'll come back
and do this if the remote isn't working
after the first programming okay turn
off the ignition
turn the ignition on with the paired key
so this is our original key
it's important there's timing
requirements so you gotta follow the
timing carefully within 30 seconds we're
going to turn off the ignition
and we're going to turn it back on now
okay it tells us there's three keys
paired to this vehicle already
turn off the ignition
turn on the ignition with an unpaired
key so that means I've got to take my
new key
pull out the working one put one of the
new ones in
turn that ignition on I'm not trying to
start the engine
and we're going to turn off the ignition
okay turn on the ignition
on these Hondas you go through that a
little bit on and off on the dashboard
right now you may notice there's a
blinking green security light and that's
normal that's part of the programming
process when the key works that light
will not be on turn off the ignition
turn on the ignition
okay we've now got four keys so this one
works
all right turn off the ignition
so turn on the ignition with an unpaired
key so we're taking our second spare key
now no key ring
I'm gonna put it in
strangely it did not get our fifth key
so no the security is not off it failed
to pair the key I'm gonna take this out
remember this is the one we haven't
programmed yet
if I try to start the engine
see how the security light turns on is
all then it's just blinking so it's not
working
I'm going to come back in here we're
gonna run this app again got a Honda
CRV and the 2001 to 2020 is the one that
had the blade key so I'm taking my
original working key turning the
ignition on
I'm not starting the engine
it's turned all the dashboard lights on
phone tells us it's busy communicating
all right
we just need to make one of these
turn off the ignition
okay turn on the ignition with a paired
key so a working key original working
cue that's already paired to the vehicle
turn off the ignition
turn on the ignition
tells me there's four Keys okay
so we know we have four Keys already for
this vehicle
turn on the ignition with an unpaired
key so I take out my original
here's that fifth key we're trying to
pair
it's now paired this fifth key
okay no more keys to be can be paired to
this vehicle maximum number
okay
turn off the ignition
turn on the ignition
okay is the security light off yes it's
off
okay so we'll say yes it's turned off
all right
key pairing is complete
all right we're done
we just made two spare keys for this
vehicle now we got three keys to use
unfortunately because this is used
vehicle there's two other keys out out
there somewhere in the world have been
lost in somebody's drawer somewhere that
start this vehicle but now we've got
three spare keys so if we lose a key
we'll always have a spare note all right
let's test the buttons let's make sure
our remotes work lock unlock
and here's the original
okay they all work
let's start the engine with this new one
fires up beautifully
second spare key works
and of course our original key still
starts the engine
so there we go can't get any easier than
that using this Universal ease installer
to make a spare key watch how amazing
this key by photo service is it's so
awesome watch how easy this is when you
find your key be sure to add the
optional Key by photo service after you
complete checkout simply upload three
pictures of your key to the website and
we'll cut your new key so it arrives
already fitting your vehicle it's that
easy
[Music]
full money back guarantee so if somehow
this fails to work for you you can reach
us via email help tomskey.com send a
message send some photos or a video let
us know what's going on if we can't help
you solve the problem ship it all back
to us and you get all your money back
it's that easy we aim to provide great
customer service because we know if
you're coming to Tom's key company you
want to save hundreds of dollars on the
cost of a spare key for your vehicle if
you have the unfortunate situation of
having lost all your car keys I'm sorry
I'm also excited to let you know that we
have a partnership that may be able to
help you go to our website find the all
keys lost page and get some help there
if you leave a comment like And
subscribe that'll help YouTube share
this video with more people it'll also
make it easier so you can find it once
your keys have arrived with the
programmer in the mail then you can
follow the video as you make spare keys
for your vehicle don't pay ripoff prices
to car dealerships for spare keys why do
you want to pay hundreds of extra
dollars to help them buy a new Tesla
when you can save those hundreds of
dollars yourself using the solutions
from Tom's key company
come check us out tomskey.com and I hope
you have a great day